cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com here's the first story from
the post-millennial ladies and gentlemen
the conspiracy theory has been proven
true in what is this five days
it's like it's like five days since they
accused Russell Brand and started going
after all of his financials trying to
get him banned from everything and then
you get NBC and a bunch of these Outlets
saying conspiracy theorists think that
there's an agenda against Russell Brand
and then a few days later UK Parliament
sends letters to social media platforms
demanding demonetization would it say
demonization is that demonization
spelling there yeah come on come on come
on post millennial I always make one of
them the monetization of Russell Brand
but I guess demonization works too it's
similar demonization although it may be
politically correct and socially easier
for rumble to join a cancel culture mob
doing so would be a violation of our
company's values and Mission so we have
this tweet from Mario novel
the the uh this is the culture median
Sports Committee of the House of Commons
sent a letter to tick tock saying while
we recognize Tick Tock is not the
creator of the content published by Mr
brand and his content may be within the
community guidelines set up by the
platforms we are concerned that he may
be able to profit from his content on
the platforms holy what dude confirmed
conspiracy against Russell Brent I'm
just really excited for this we have a
very quick confirmation of a government
conspiracy against Russell Brand wait
hold on here's the rumble tweet because
Rumble is awesome they they of course
released this with a statement saying
today we received an extremely
disturbing letter from a committee chair
in the UK Parliament while Rumble
obviously deplores sexual assault rape
in all serious crimes and believes that
both alleged victims and the accused are
entitled to full and serious
investigation it is vital to note that
the recent allegations against Russell
Brand have nothing to do with content on
rumble's platform just yesterday YouTube
announced that based solely on these
media accusations it was barring Mr bran
from monetizing his video content Rumble
stands for very different values we have
devoted ourselves to the vital cause of
Defending a free internet meaning an
internet where no one arbitrarily
dictates which ideas can or cannot be
heard or which citizens may or may not
be entitled to a platform we regard it
as deeply inappropriate and dangerous
the UK Parliament would attempt to
control who was allowed to speak on our
platform or to earn a living from doing
so singling on an individual and
demanding his ban is even more
disturbing given the absence of any
connection between the allegations and
his content on Rumble we don't agree
with the behavior of many Rumble
creators but we refuse to penalize them
for actions that have nothing to do with
our platform although it may be
politically and socially easier for
rumble to join a cancel culture mob
doing so would be a violation of our
company's values and Mission we
emphatically reject the UK parliament's
demands and and here we have this letter
to Chris Chris pavlovsky the CEO of
Rumble saying I am writing concerning
the serious allegations regarding
Russell Brand the contact in the context
of his being an accountant produce arm
Rumble with more than 1.4 million
followers the culture media and Sports
Committee is Raising questions with the
broadcasters and production companies
who previously employed Mr brand to
examine both the culture of the industry
in the past and whether that culture
still prevails today that is to say they
have outright admitted the UK government
is reaching out to other networks asking
them to remove Russell Russell Brand and
take away his income because he was
accused
allegations from a decade to two decades
ago this is amazing
they say they said we are also looking
at the gist of social media including on
Rumble where he issued his preemptive
response to the accusations made against
him by the Sunday Times and channel 4
dispatches while we recognize that
Rumble is not the creator of the content
published by Mr brand we are concerned
that he may be able to profit from his
content on the platform think about what
they're saying right here the UK
government is outright saying if you
commit any crime ever you should not be
allowed to live
at all what does Russell Brand do for a
living he's a personality he's an actor
he communicates he talks they take his
shows down they try to take his podcast
down YouTube actually demonetizes his
show they're basically saying he should
not be allowed to make a living anymore
for any reason even though he's never
been convicted of a crime or I should
say I don't know if he's been kicked of
any crime but in this instance he's only
been accused well he hasn't even been
accused on a criminal level right it was
just the article that came out I mean
it's a pure there is an investigation
but because of the article right right
right right so and it seems like
especially with things like YouTube it
seems like that I mean we're in the age
of the open conspiracy essentially at
this point where YouTube is sitting
there going man we really wish we could
kick Russell Brand off but we can't just
do it outright if only if somebody came
out with an article nudge nudge hint
hint and so they're just working in this
almost reciprocal way and I mean you
know Rumble says we're fighting for free
speech on the internet that age is
rapidly ending we have the EU Digital
Services act the UK Parliament just
passed the uh what is it the Online
safety bill which ironically when it was
in draft form was presided over by the
same woman that sent this letter
Carolina denange or whatever her name is
so yeah it's it's coming to an end
pretty rapidly this whole uh free speech
thing we've been enjoying so long well I
mean this is the UK I I think we're
actually we have to remain steadfast but
I think we're doing a really good job in
the U.S as it pertains to the boycotts
and the boycotts the fact that Rumble
exists shows that we have started to
push back and we are gaining ground
Russell Brand they can't take away his
money because Rumble said no everyone
else bends the knee but I love the
precedent set by YouTube so what now all
anyone has to do to terminate someone's
account is just accuse them or have
someone accuse them I mean this is all
all awful uh sufficiently horrifying for
me to be like all right we need to
completely isolate uh social media from
governments this is something that we've
been aware of or we the Twitter files
have shown that their government's
interested in accessing the power and
influence that comes from social media
to think that you know other governments
aren't doing it with you know just
because the U.S has has been exposed and
they're supposed to be efforts being
undertaken to to prevent it doesn't mean
that other countries aren't going to try
to apply the same pressure and it's for
essentially the same things they're
looking to end the Liberty to speak your
mind and say say things that are
controversial you've got that Jacinda I
forget what her last name is the prime
minister of New Zealand specifically
coming out and saying things that 15
years ago if you said publicly you'd
have gotten excoriated for it you would
have been you would have been thrown
right into the bin with Stalin Hitler
and all the other authoritarians Paul
pot whatever all of them and and now
it's looked at as something that people
have become so numb to the efforts at
limiting what you're allowed to say and
what you can't say that that these kinds
of behaviors from governments you know
only the the alternative media seems to
take issue with it and it's a big
problem and obviously we're all pretty
much here in agreement and it's I'm
thankful that that Rumble did what they
did
but this speaks to the attitude of
governments and it's not just the United
States government it's governments
across the western western world
yeah I just don't I don't think social
media I don't think this is uh an
imposition on social media I think
social media is uh happy to go along
with it actually happy to have the
excuse to ban the people that they
wanted to ban in the first place I agree
100 and the reason there are people that
are out there that are going to say oh
you know it's because of money it's not
because of money it's because of access
because if they do what the government
wants then the government becomes
friendly with them and that's power it's
beyond money because Google doesn't need
money well you know it's also it is
access to a certain degree there's also
fear sure if you're if you're a a
company say you're an email service
provider or maybe you're a tech company
and uh some guys in black suits show up
to your office and they start going like
listen here you know we uh need your
help taking out the uh terrorists if you
know what I'm saying otherwise things
could get messy for you it's funny
basically what they do yeah and that's
always exactly the tone of that letter
that they send because they don't say
demonetize Russell Brand they say we're
awful can concerned that he may be
making money you would hate to have that
on your conscience wouldn't you yeah
it's it's a mafia style Shakedown
absolutely how long before they shut
Rumble down that's the question or
attempt to obviously Rumble you know I
think back to parlor remember what
happened with parlor thank God Rumble
has built the infrastructure necessary
they can be able to broadcast him how
long before they attempt in some
capacity because now it's Rumble and
perhaps Twitter against the government I
don't want to make the joke that I that
I need to make so I mean I just can't I
can't but
let's just say that there are a series
of attempts to assassinate the
characters of key individuals who are
playing vital roles and it seems like
their only strategy with now Tim Ballard
is being accused it's like here's a guy
who's married and has nine kids and
they're like oh look it was him too and
it's just like oh come on like Russell
Brand you have people being like well he
was a promiscuous guy I mean man this
could be true I hope it's not and then
you have people they're accusing Tim
Ballard and it's like oh come on yeah
like the dude who's Halfway Around the
World hunting down child traffickers had
time to go and get out of here with this
stuff but then you got Howard Stern out
there saying the most outlandish things
and he can't get canceled he even said
today it was the headline I am woke yeah
I am woke I mean that's he literally
just he might as well have said please
don't cancel me I will lay down and I
will kiss the boot I will put the whole
soul right in my mouth he I mean it is
it is embarrassing but when you have the
history that Howard Stern says you're
left with few options because all it
takes is someone getting a uh their hair
a hair across their ass and they're
gonna come after you and you have just
more evidence than you could ever
possibly deflect from here's the best
thing about Rumble Rumble has a payment
processor they have their own servers
they have their own hosting
they are building out everything they
need so that they cannot remove them now
what they did with uh parlor was a
coordinated uh blocking of it from a
bunch of different app stores these
tactics aren't working
it worked for parlor sure and then
Rumble pops up everyone learned what
happened because everyone knew that
Amazon you know messed with their uh
their servers or whatever they shut down
parlor on false reasons they basically
said that January Sixers were using it
whatever and it's like they used
Facebook more than they used part of
course and then Elon Musk buys Twitter
and turns it into X and they're freaking
out screaming and just losing I look you
know shout out to Elon Musk for buying
the platform and and building it now
they're running this I don't know if you
guys saw this lie that Elon Musk wants
to charge all users which was not what
happened and they're using that to just
like they are spreading this propaganda
because they're trying to get people to
leave Twitter so they can regain control
of the narrative the real story was that
Elon said something the effect of the
only way to deal with all the Bots would
be if you were to charge everyone like a
small fee which you know we're trying to
figure out how to deal with and they're
like he says he's gonna charge everybody
money and then Elon comes out and he's
like I'm not saying we're going to
charge everyone money I'm saying that is
how you get rid of bots but of course
the media runs the narrative and then a
bunch of people sign up for blue sky or
whatever because they're trying to
regain control they're losing and
they're also launching investigations
into Tesla and SpaceX and I mean it you
know they go after you however they can
and obviously what it's about is that
they want a total control of the
information flow because that is in this
information age that's how you control
people you control what goes into their
mind thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time